I think. That's right. That's right. Ok. My name's eddie boots. I'm an architect and.
An environmental activist i suppose you could call me. I've been living in the syria for eighteen years. In fact.
I arrived here. The year after the queries festival. We were in fact. Overseas during the. Aquarius festival.
Traveling through southeast asia and other places on to europe and then back again. And when we arrived back from.
From our trip. All our friends were telling us about the aquarius festival.
And prior to our overseas trip we already decided to. Get out of sydney. We were living in sydney i had a practice.
To take short practice in sydney and.
I wasn't very satisfied with my practice or my lifestyle and we wanted to move into the country.
We felt that we could do some things that we weren't able to do in the city. Basically live a more laid back lifestyle.
Unpolluted that. Miss phoebe. We were living in belle maine.
And we had the colgate palmolive factory right next to us we used to belch.
Huge billowing clouds of black smoke out every night. Not during the day only at night and. We we saw.
I felt we were suffocating a bit. Even though it was a pleasant place to live in the rain in lots of other respects.
So we'd already made up our minds that we were going to leave the city and. Set up somewhere in the country.
But we had no idea where we were going to in fact travel around australia looking for a place.
So anyway when we came back from from our overseas trip.
As i said before our friends were talking about their queries festival. And name been. So we thought well.
We'll check out. Nimbin first before we do the rest of the straight.
And so we came out while still living in sydney we. We made an excursion. Up here and.
Sort of fell in love with the place immediately and. Found quite a lot of people. Post the queer us.
People who decided to stay on the tundra bull. And various other places and. So there.
We made the decision there in that this was where we'd come to and. We found a house and land.
We found that the house in bel maine which we still owed money on but.
We found that we could sell that one for the proceeds we could buy this piece of land here in linden and.
And we'd have a bit of change left over to guide us through and hopefully we got some income.
So that's how we came to be here in nine hundred seventy four the year of the big. Lismore flood.
All our belongings arrived in lismore and went into hensley's storage. Which was perched. Above the river.
And the floods came and the river rose and rose and rose and we thought our stuff was going to float away.
It came to within inch within an inch of. Of our belongings. And then. Thankfully. Receded.
So that was our introduction to nimbin wait. Those the first years were very weight. The piece of land.
And the house that we'd bought. Already had occupancy in it. People who had been raining or squatting camping.
But we all fitted in very nicely together. We leave. We. We lived in. Shared the house basically. And.
Started life in the country. We were totally inexperienced. We were charged up with a lot of idealism and.
We had lots of ideas about what we wanted to see happen. But we had very little the reality of living in the country.
So the first few years were really. Discovering what it was all about. Starting up gardens and orchards.
Rebuilding the house which was. Daily livable. It was a sort of. Rundown. Country. Cottage. But not.
Not one of your classical veranda. Places but a jerry built sort of joint. And so we.
We started rebuilding the house and then we got involved with.
The what was quickly growing community of new settlers from all over the. Country.
There were first of all there were people that were left over from the aquarius first of all the ones who didn't even
bother leaving. Or those who went. Went away and. Reorganize themselves.
Their affairs and then came back to leave here and from then on there was a stream of people coming to the area and.
Most of us. Faced similar difficulties housing and and. And schooling. And so probably one of the first.
Community things we were involved in was setting up the community school. Which incidentally still operating. So that.
You know at least. The education part was going to be taken care of daughter. Was tane up the.
Tane at the time i think and. And there were lots of other people who were in a similar situation. Mainly.
Professionals or. Students or. You know young graduates.
A very highly qualified lot actually refute g.'s from the cities mainly sydney and melbourne.
But other capital cities as well. And so. My first involvement was the school. Pretty soon along the way. My next.
Sort of main interest became. What became known as the home builders association.
Under the circumstances that we were facing here a lot of people moved on to vacant blocks of land.
I think that someone. Right. So yeah there were years and people fought. Right in. So in the seventy's.
In the early seventy's as people were rising he finding that. Often they were moving on to. They can pieces of land.
Buying land and. Buying into communities and there was no housing for them. So they pictured tain and.
And very rudimentary shelters and. Try and cope with the weather. The leeches and the ticks and.
And all the rest of it and so shelter became a very important first step. Getting them.
Getting set up so that you were out of the weather. And so. People generally came with very little capital.
They couldn't afford to get someone to build them a house. That was almost totally out of the question.
So what people did was they became. Own the builders. They bought. And scavenged materials. Bought second hand stuff.
And scavenge that. Wherever they could find it and used. Poles and. You know which they'd cut. They'd cut trees.
On their properties. And they used these materials to put up their houses. Now.
And they were very innovative and very interesting houses. However the council didn't find them.
Innovative or interesting. They found the total affront to their regulations. And so. While they turned a blind eye.
Because they didn't really know how to cope with it. But then there was a police raid on a on a property.
The rainy away. Rainy a valley. Wallace road. Actually and. It was to do with marijuana.
And i can't remember whether there were drugs on the place or not but. As a result of it. The police.
Made a complaint to the council. Saying that this property had more buildings on it than were permitted.
And because of the police complaint the council was obliged to send their inspectors out.
Which they did and the inspectors. Inspected the buildings and was. They found that there were three.
Three more buildings. On the site.
Them were allowed in that the buildings didn't comply with regulations in various ways. You know.
Maybe the ceiling height wasn't quite right. Or they might have had a loft in them which.
In those days the lofts were recognized. And so. They are the owners of the property to demolish.
The excess houses and fix up what was left to meet regulations. These people were prepared to do that.
They put a lot of love and if it. Into building the shelters and. Had no intention of. Demolishing any of them.
And eventually things came to a head they had a number of warnings and then the.
Next thing was the council issued them with a demolition order which said. If you don't.
Demolish we're going to come out and do it for you. Well they. They got in touch with friends and.
Pretty soon the network of. New settlers in the area.
Alerted to what was about to happen and most of us were in very similar circumstances.
So we had a meeting in the in the media center. Which is where we are and a hundred people turned up.
And we formed the home builders association which was. Initially it was formed to.
To stop council from going ahead with the demolition. And then grew to be an organization that generally fos the and.
Assisted the process of home building. In the area. Did a lot of communal projects we organize work gangs.
Work days on various properties. Put up places and. Had facilities and so on.
And we are open negotiations with that with the council and. A group of us.
Carry these negotiations on with council for quite a number of years. You know buildings were ever demolished.
And gradually we. We convinced council with the systems of the state government. Excuse me.
Who are very sympathetic to our cause and i'll come to that in a minute. With assistance of the state government we.
We have we got implemented. Multiple occupancy. Planning regulations which. Recognized more than.
The perscribe number of buildings. Per acreage that. That was in the in the in the regulations at that time.
Recognize the need. Allowed more buildings and.
And we also started to get council loosened up on some of their interpretations of. Building by laws.
As real as regards materials things like mud brick and recycled material. Pole frames and stuff like that and also we.
We got them to recognize. Aloft by. We were allowed to build lofts because we had.
But we had to call them storage spaces. But then we'd sleep in them. And i think. Named and sort of.
Pioneered the loft. We. You know there's so many houses with lofts in them because they are very handy.
Way of utilizing space. I mean we had to confront them on a whole range of building issues you know for instance.
There was one house that. Didn't have a wall.
As far as the council's concerned you cannot have a house with or without a war. You must have a wall.
So when when is a wall a wall and when is a blank space or a or a tree or a or a vase. When does that become a wall.
Enclosed space so we had these ridiculous arguments with them about matters of the.
During all this time we had terrific input from. People in sydney university. And. They helped us.
With the whole process of getting multiple occupancy happening and the loosening up of the regulations
and recognition of other building. Forms of you know the ones the council was used to. Let's see. I've got it.
I've got to draw my breath. Going son. We had a lot of help from the state government.
And at that time it was never all rain. And the labor government. And there. And there was a particularly sympathetic.
Minister for planning. Paul enda. Unfortunately died a few years ago. A young man. And he was.
He was quite enthusiastic about what we were doing and. Very supportive. So he helped change the state. Planning laws.
Polenta was also involved in another matter of great interest to us at the time. And. And this is. This is my other.
One of my other great passions if you can call it that. Which relates to the environment. Now.
In in the early in the mid seventy's. A group of new settlers in their ania. Became aware that the forest.
At the end of the. The virgin rain forest that they're in their valley. Was about to be logged.
And they began to organize resistance to it. Generally trying to persuade the forestry commission of the following.
Folly of. That course of action. They weren't successful the forestry commission is pretty intractable now.
In those days. They were totally a law unto themselves and. And weren't. Into any public input whatsoever.
They were unsuccessful the campaign. Went on for a number of years until in one thousand nine hundred seventy nine.
The bulldozers started moving in. Again. This network of people was alerted and. Hundreds of us from around the valley.
Nearby to raney and the people in terrain itself. Went to the forest and blockaded the bulldozers.
I think most people have probably heard about rain here. It was probably the first major environmental direct action.
You know strayer. And it set the pace and the start of many future. Environmental actions. For me it was a real.
I opened because i'd been aware of rain forests. When i moved up here i became aware of rain forests there were.
You know around us and it sort of had a look here and there. But i didn't really know. What they were about.
And the terrain your protest really. Crystallize the environmental concerns. Because he was.
He was a rain forest which. I discovered was one of the most copper complex. Ecosystems on the planet.
With an amazing diverse the of flora and fauna.
We lived in the forest during this protest we were there all the time we were in and we were up and down trees
and we were in front of the bulldozers and we were running off into the forest. Playing. Chasings with the police.
And this went on for a number of weeks. So there was there was this mass conversion of people.
To the defense of the rain forest. People just really got turned on to what. Rain forest was about. And and for me.
It led to an involvement in rain forest protection from that time onwards. And pole end it was.
I started this off by saying paul and was involved well. Paul ndaa. Again. Gave support to the.
To our pleas for protecting the forest and. Well this is history now. The logging. Was stopped. An inquiry was set up.
Which dragged on for a year and spent a million dollars and it was never really used. The result.
We're never really used by that time other events. Caught up with with the rainy and.
Fairly soon after all those areas became part of what eventually became world heritage area is in nineteen eighty two.
There was a similar similar. Forest protest. Here in the night cap range. Well i think it did.
I think it did then not well. Named been named in. You could say became the front line of environmental defense.
Out of the protests. Came other similar protests. The night cap. Range. Middle head. Beach. This was.
This was in the rain forest forest matter this was saying mining of the beach. On the on the north coast.
But it was again it was driven by.
The protest was driven by a concern that he was a pristine environment being destroyed for. Short profit. And i mean.
I mean there were also. They were extracting minerals which were going into. Atomic warheads and so on so the.
Were all these other aspects involved and. We were very. Much against that that that. Campaign incidentally was lost.
The beach. The beach was mined the forest. The forest and they were destroyed. Also in nineteen eighty two.
While the nightcap. Protest was happening. Tasmania in tasmania. The. The. Franklin was under threat.
And the tasmanian environmentalists was starting to get organized.
To see what they could do and they were very interested in what we were doing here. In those same grippers in.
To talk to us and see what we were doing. And we kept in constant touch. Until. Until in must be in late.
Nineteen eighty two. Work started on the franklin. And the blockade of the franklin began. And many people from me.
Well perhaps. Like myself. They packed their kids' few belongings into kombi van zyl and. Other vehicles.
And made the trek down to tassie. And then in spain. Three months on the river. And we. We had a.
We had a lot to offer. We expect we were the sort of front line. If you like to call it that we were.
We were we went to the blockade on the river. The. Tasmanian wilderness society organized. The race. They.
They got the boats together they train people in nonviolent action they had camps they organize supply lines.
Radio communications. It was a beautifully done. Job and. We did our part by doing the work up front.
With the police and the workers and the barges that came up the river. And of course. Educated and.
I think another generation. Almost you could say of. Of young. Astray and. Because it was it was.
Holiday time and students from all over the country came to help with the blockade. And we.
They had this crash course of environmental awareness. And environmental action. And of course then.
That came pain went on to nineteen eighty three. Until the labor government. One office. And put a stop to.
Well they didn't they actually quite put a stop to it but. Signalled their intention to stop.
And there was followed a protracted legal process in the high court. Eventually stopping the.
Struction the destruction. Can we pause for a minute. Quite true.
I hope they're right but i think it's quite true that nimbin has been the breeding ground of green extremists.
Yes and i think that's one of its major contributions to a story in society. I mean if you look back.
If you look at the twenty years since. Aquarius. There's been an enormous leap in. Environmental awareness.
Throughout the whole country. It's. It's now. Mainstream that a way in this. It wasn't there twenty years ago and.
And i think named and played a very the people in named and played played a major role in getting that awareness.
Happening. And continuing it. And i hope. Will continue to play a role in the future. So yes.
There they can be labeled as extremist we can be labeled as extremists but. We feel that.
These are extreme times i mean what we saw was it was unbridled exploitation of resources.
Natural resources which are really the commonwealth. They're not the to be taken by.
Vested interests someone out there for a quick buck. They belong to all of us they belong to our children.
And we weren't prepared to stand by and. You know see see them and raped. Absolutely no apologies. Big thing.
There's lot. So the vision. The vision. You know twenty years ago and and.
The years since then have brought waves of new settlers. Bringing their ideals and visions for the for the.
For the future and. I've mentioned. I've mentioned the home building and the environment. As.
Some of the things that people got involved in.
Well there were lots of other visions they really spread across across the whole spectrum of human activity
and endeavor and. Ranging from home birth. For instance birthing. We wanted to see our kids. Born in a stress free.
Nonclinical. Environment. So. Home birthing. And again we're sitting in the building where. Home birthing was born.